at long last the blue jays have a home
ball park for the 2020 season it is the
ballpark of their aaa affiliate the
buffalo bisons it is salem field blue
jays will send their ace to the mountain
ryu coming off a terrific outing last
time on and we're underway at salem
field jonathan vr leading it off for the
marlins he is their shortstop hitting
195 on the season
curveball and he got him
the r strikes out on a breaking ball up
above the belt for the first out at
salem field ryu deals
here's a hot shot out to second base
gloved by kevin biggio sidearm sling
over to first dickerson's retired and so
are the miami marlins the blue jays will
take their hacks as the home team in
buffalo for eliezer hernandez making his
second start of the year just the second
marlin starter to be able to say that
unbelievably disciplined at the plate
but he goes down looking a strikeout for
hernandez his first
ryan batting 303 10 for 33.
here's a swing at a fly ball out to deep
left field turning around guriel and he
will watch it go into the screen brian
anderson sends one to the jet stream his
third home run of the season is a
lead-off shot in the second inning in
miami has a one-nothing lead
cervelli who's hitting 192-5 for 26.
guerrero going down the line makes the
catch flatty with an over-the-shoulder
catch with his back to the infield
and a runner in scoring position for the
blue jays
and a ground ball what a play at short
vr up with it throws to first and dug
out by forsyth terrific play by jonathan
vr to take a hit away from vlad and make
the play at first base vr fully extended
two down here is joe panic
yeah the umpire called obstruction right
there as
guerrero was on top and now
rivera is going to go there the umpire
pointed as if he said yeah there's
contact by the defensive player
absolutely watch this what's the umpire
here and he says hey you're holding him
down you're holding him now now he's
going to say that
yep obstruction and i'm surprised that
they haven't made this call earlier
could it be a situation jp where maybe
the play was he was out by enough that
it wouldn't have made that big of a
difference i think that because of that
he's going to be out engine ryu goes
back to work runner not going and it's
strike three call
fifth strikeout for ryu here's monte
harrison who struck out leading off the
third
got him right at the knees and you can
see how harrison felt about that call
two down
yeah he thought it was low but the
empire rings him up so he strikes out
for a second time number six on the
night for hanjin ryu back-to-back
strikeouts here in the fifth randall
grichik rounded out to third base his
first time up here's the pitch
and it's chase swung on and missed
richard goes down on strikes five
strikeouts now for eliezer he's working
here in the fifth
birdie waiting
and the one-two pitch
high strike has called on bertie and he
can't believe it well
maybe it's the western new york weather
but the strike zone is expanding and
contracting tonight
curveball sounded like maybe a broken
bat shaw up within the third
and the marlins go in order a very nice
job by hungen ryu can the bats get going
now cabin biggio oh for two a strikeout
in a fly ball third time through the
order beginning right now for the blue
jays first pitch swinging bishop with a
fly ball down the left field line this
is pretty well head and it's going to be
off the top of the wall jansen will be
at third on the play must not have been
comfortable or sure that it was going to
get over the head of dickerson so he was
taking no chances so a real opportunity
for the blue jays second and third with
nobody out and here's bo buchet
one two is hit high in the air to left
field dickerson back
gone
three run homer for beau buschette
and the blue jays take the lead
got the marlins for two then got the
raise in over the weekend long throw
bushette and scoop nicely by vladi at
the other end
good play on both ends there
the shed acknowledging the good play by
blatty over at first he scooped that low
throw
a second walk in the end will push
grichik down to second base
balls well struck into right center and
down for a base hit
grichik will round third and race home
jansen into third on an rbi single by
biggio and it's four to one
okay oscar hernandez out to
center and john bernie makes the play
first defensive inning out there in
center field and john birdie tracks one
down
the marlins worked the walk with brian
anderson up there first and third and
here is francisco cervelli
with a drive out to left and
go on a home run to tie it
two outs in the ninth cervelli evens
things up no way paul
i said three two count you walk a hitter
on a slider to get
to the tying run and cervelli swings at
a 3-0 pitch and goes yard
green
light and we will see logan foresight
now foresight hits one a ton
down the left field line but it is foul
or is it it is a home run and that ball
boy that looked like that ball
yeah foul ball
of course a run wins it right here
alfred at third biggio with second of a
shed at first one down 2-2 on the way
and a swing and a base hit into right
field and they will win it
travis shaw drives in anthony alford
with a winning run
and the blue jays are victorious
in their first game in buffalo